I didn't want to go to school
I didn't want to die
uh my mom said i did
uh better if i stayed home
several schools in the Netherlands are closing their doors
because they got 1 threat notification
for example,
it is shared on snapchat
that 1 shooting will happen
uh people just forwarded a lot of things
that there is 1 kind of school
shooting would be on snap was sent on snap anyway
they would shoot at school
this school in Amsterdam
has remained open despite urges
yes you do play with lives
for the day your school may not have happened now
but suppose what would happen
and then she'll let us go to school
that could be Uhm life so often SAY
but why does one school close and the other not
uh it can always be that for 1
specific school there is something more going on
and that is why every school becomes as soon as it experiences this uh uh
always that
contacted the police at 1
get advice for that school
on one side
yes we all love the day off
but on the other hand
yes it is just better
because people have exams so it is also annoying for that
so yeah
we just want it good that we have been open
and if the school remains open
how seriously should you take such a threat
probably the copy amount is
and we see that
well probably not
reel is that at all these 20 schools and even more
the threat actually prevents that
but of course we remain sharp and alert
I think it was just 1 exam student or something
who didn't feel like taking the exam
had not learned that well and thought of it
it's funny to do
such a threatening message is not such a smart joke
you can get 1 prison sentence for it